1010 a while I can't believe it double
man that's it you made it
Impractical Joker Stars mer and Q
celebrate 10 seasons of their hit prank
series you called it well I said early
on yeah I did but it wasn't serious Oh I
thought you were serious we'll be here
at least ten years before I said 10
seasons and then we'll do a movie yeah
you you actually called who I was gonna
marry too long before I met my wife yeah
you're right yeah he's right well I
think we got another seven seasons yeah
the jokester started the hidden camera
show 13 years ago with their best
friends Sal vulcano and Joe Gatto who's
since retired I remember the first day
of shooting we did not know this
restaurant yeah yeah Chinatown Brasserie
not there anymore no it's up there uh we
didn't even know what the show was back
then yeah right we had no idea well also
our crew consisted of the four of us and
eight other people yeah yeah it was wild
man that was those are the old days so
what did newly famed mer and Q spend
their first big paychecks on
uh wow what is the first big purchase I
don't even know if I made it I've been
saying for years that I was gonna buy a
DeLorean I wanted a DeLorean and and at
first I was gonna get a season five and
the season five came and I didn't get it
then season eight now season 10. so one
of these days I will buy a DeLorean I
have a surprise for you
I bought a glory for myself oh no can I
ride it
local guys from Staten Island we we
hoard our money like squirrels or nuts
uh that being said I I didn't own a car
until two years ago think about it the
46 I bought my first car two years ago
so that was my first big purchase as for
if they ever saw this fandom coming
their way oh I don't think I ever felt
that sort of confidence at any point I
mean I I uh I always feel very I know
the show people love it but I I have
problems with myself and I I'm not
allowed to attach any positive things to
anything I do I think his show was was
very popular around season three is when
we started yeah yeah I can't talk about
my show uh I think season three is when
I noticed yeah
yeah I think when we started touring
live uh you know you shouldn't hidden
camera show you have no idea if it's
affecting people in any way yeah uh and
we started performing live and we're on
our fifth national tour now and uh when
fans would come out and you would sell
out larger and larger venues like holy
cow this is resonating with people in a
way we could not have anticipated yep
murder q and Sal are hitting the road
for their latest live tour and here's
what fans can expect wow okay ready for
this the brand new live Impractical
Jokers tour features never before seen
clips from the show stories from our
lives stuff the network wouldn't let us
air we air in the Arenas and we finally
tell the story of my way I got married
two years ago and my wedding is very
likely responsible for the breakup of
the band Smash Mouth yeah not likely is
responsible for the for the breakup of
the band's Smash Mouth for those missing
Joe on tour the guys say they're not
ruling out any future appearances and I
certainly would want to work with you
yeah me too he's still our best friend
has always been our best friend who's
the best man of my wedding and is is
probably he's probably the one
responsible for Smash Mouth I would say
yeah most likely I was like but you know
he's Irreplaceable so we decided not to
even try to replace him
for more than a decade the Jokers have
kept America laughing and this February
they're coming back for more
hit the music when it comes to the show
they're full-on Pros the payer spills on
how they come up with new ideas after
over a decade of pranks we spend like a
month at the top of a season kind of
brainstorming ideas and whenever one of
us leaves the room or the zoom or what
have you the others conspire against him
uh so you never want to leave if you're
there you can't I just wear a diaper now
when I go in so I don't have to leave
the room and with this many years under
their belt they're also having to find
new ways to disguise their faces if you
notice Q's beard is red they're a part
of it the reason is uh two weeks ago we
filmed with him and we put him in full
Prosthetics full yeah it doesn't look
like me did not look like you at all I
would not have recognized you if I saw
you it looks so real you would think
that the Prosthetics wouldn't look real
in person when we put me in it I was
like oh I would fall for this yeah it
totally would fall it looks great in
person yeah on top of mercury and Sal's
hilarious Antics fans are in for a treat
this season with tons of celeb cameos
season 10 we've got some of our dear
friends uh uh for from over the years of
Joker's uh guests performing with us
we've got John Mayer Kesha Brett
Michaels Paul Rudd Anthony Davis post
Malone
uh the favorite for me was uh you know Q
is a massive Evil Dead fan
and uh I mean Bruce Campbell is your
favorite I mean I've always had like a
crush on Bruce Campbell my entire life
so we got him to be on the show and uh
punished Q yeah they used him against
being a punishment I had one good
conversation with Bruce and then they
told him do not be nice to him on or off
camera for the rest of the day and man
did he relish that opportunity he was he
was brilliant I got made a fool of by
John Mayer in front of his fans yeah
John Mayer's playing a concert berated
me in front of his fan base and they
cheered when he berated me it's great TV
and looks like more seasons could be on
the horizon uh you know uh we said uh
when we first created the show that we
would do it as long as we were still
having fun doing it and we are still
having an absolute blast and I think it
shows in season 10 so as long as uh we
have fun and people like it we'll keep
doing it
[Music]
foreign